luis miranda is a former DNC
communications director and he joins us
tonight
Lys thanks a lot for coming on hey
thanks Tucker I appreciate the
opportunity to have an honest
conversation on this particularly as
we're all just remembering President
George HW Bush who taught us that we can
disagree on some of these issues but do
it respectfully so I really had the
chance to do this yeah I went to the
Capitol yesterday just after leaving the
studio to see him took my kids and that
was one of the things we talked about is
that there's gonna be different
perspectives on these issues but we can
talk about them respect right and I
think what you've laid out here brings
up some very legitimate issues the
question is so there's that that's what
I like about what's happening in Tijuana
and I feel deeply for the people of
Tijuana because I think they're going
through what if a lot of Americans have
gone through but because it is t 1 and
it is Mexico we can't dismiss them as
anti-hispanic and so we have to look
more clearly at what their concerns are
and so my question to you is a very
simple and looking at the concerns that
we just played on tape and those are
real does it make you a little more
empathetic toward our fellow Americans
who have similar feelings I think we
have to be empathetic all around here
which includes people who have
legitimate concerns but a lot of those
concerns are being stoked without a
basis of reality and and so here's the
problem that a lot of these immigrants
that are part of this Caravan are decent
people who are fleeing either violence
or economic situations that are
untenable but they're victims all around
because they're being victimized by
human traffickers and smugglers that
want to take advantage of them that I
grant that you and so there's actually
an AP analysis that just came out that
4,000 of these people have disappeared
in the last few years on the way in
other words their families have no idea
what happened to them they either got
murdered or worse just along the way and
so there's a legitimate humanitarian
crisis of people who were being taken
agree with that eyes on that and I
totally agree but I just want to shine
the light on the victims who don't
really get representation of any kind in
the press and those are the citizens who
are having to absorb large populations
of and I agree with you largely decent
people I think most migrants want what I
want which is a better family for their
better life for their families I guess
it's exactly right what super criminals
know I've always thought that this is
not but I think it's really but it's
important to empathize as deeply with
the citizens
whose lives are being upended by the
arrival of these immigrants as is with
the immigrants themselves so when you
see this can you say that you know
American citizens say I don't want any
more immigration we've we've had more
than we can handle
they're not just racists are they I mean
they have a point do they not I don't
think they're racists I think it's
important that they also understand the
other side of this which is that
immigrants have actually made our
economy a lot stronger through the years
you touched on it a little bit at the
beginning let me add some color to that
which includes that our population is
ageing we have baby boomers retiring and
a lot of the people that we are able to
replace in the economy are because of
immigration now we want to do that
ideally in a legal and orderly fashion
but hold on I need to ask I need to ask
this question you say our population is
aging
we're not reproducing ourselves why do
you think that is nobody seems to pause
and ask why can't you Americans afford
to get married and have children afford
to buy homes and cars and their solution
the elite solutions will just bring in
new people but what about the Americans
the young people the 30 year old
American I can't afford to have kids
does anybody care about that person I
mean maybe there's a real problem here
that we what really because I never hear
that person addressed ever
it's an industrialized country issue
more than America but hold on I'm an
American okay so my concern is for my
fellow Americans and they can't afford
to have children but rather than fix
their problems or even think about them
or like we'll just import new children
to approach this we should be able to do
both look over the last ten years
American companies and stocks have
outperformed the rest of the world by a
lot American companies and the economy
have been so strong over the last ten
years compared to anything else in the
world and part of the reason for that is
because we have an economy that is
constantly renewing itself and so we
absolutely should be able to have an
economy where people who want to have
children can do so but it doesn't mean
what we do space to absorb it no no no
but that's not what you're saying hold
on you just said we need to bring in
people because Americans aren't
reproducing in sufficient numbers and my
question is why aren't our leaders
thinking about how our people can afford
to have children they don't even
consider that a subject worth studying
much less trying to fix it's just like
oh well
they're not having enough kids but
here's enough those aren't mutually
exclusive you know you're saying that
our low birth rates are the
justification for immigration I'm saying
our low birth rates are a tragedy that
say something awful about our economy
and the selfish stupidity of our leaders
that combination of our growth and our
prosperity that is enables us to have a
stronger economy so there's there's
definitely a both sides to this where
you can look at well who are gonna be
hurt but when you looked at states like
Georgia and others that have implemented
anti-immigrant measures that forced a
lot of these immigrants out what you saw
was you know food rotting on the vines a
lot of lost crops because there weren't
enough people there to work them and so
the reality is is that we can both do
something that's actually economy for
people who are suffering is so and who
are American and who have lived here
their whole lives they want to have
children they want have an opportunity
to do better than yet there maybe
someone should care about them a little
bit absolutely it's the most important
thing that we have to demonize the
immigrants who are legitimate demonizing
anybody I'm not against the immigrants I
understand for Americans and nobody
cares about them it's like shut up
you're dying we're gonna replace you and
it's deeply if anyway right I hope you
will come back because I enjoyed that
conversation thank you likewise thank
you